Let'sgonexttoourcolorfromthe757areacode,who'scallingtodayfrom757.
HiDavid,thisisMikeis...
Hey,Mike,canIamcalling?Becauserecently,Ikindofswitchedsidesfromnotreallyfromleftto
right,butonpositionsinvolvingabortion,andIwaswonderingwhyyouwouldn'tconsiderabortion
humanrightsissue.
I,the...Sowhenwesayahumanrightsissuedifferentpeoplemeandifferentthings.Ithinkthere's
noquestionthattheissueofabortionrelatestotherightsofhumans,it'sspecificallywomenandthe
peoplethattheyarepotentially,inrelationshipswiththatcouldleadtooffspringtodecidewhatis
bestfortheminthesituationinwhichtheyfindthemselves.Sointhatcase,itisahumanrights
issue.Butsometimespeoplemeansomethingveryspecificwhentheysayahumanrightsissue.So
maybetellmemoreofwhatyou'rethinking.
Yeah,I'mthinkingofadifferentperspectiveasin...So,sayababyorifyouwannacallitafee,I
guess,ifwecanagreeifTishumanisafeeishuman.
Sothisgetsimmediatelyintoaquestionthatscience­religionandphilosophyallhavedifferent
viewson...It'ssortoflikewiththeissueof,isafetus.
SoItypically...Well,atwhatpointinthepregnancy,conceptionis,Iguesswecouldset...
Idon'tbelievethatafetusatconception,isafetus.Firstofall,atthatpoint,Idon'tevenknowthat
wecallitafetusandIdon'tthinkit'sapersonatthatpoint.
Okay,right,it'snotaperson.'causepersonhoodislikea...Athingbutthehumanityofit,thisis
whereIkindachangedmypositionisthatIcheckeditoutfromascienceperspective,anditseems
tome,yeah,that"Conceptioniswherehumanitystarts.HumanDNAwouldequalhumanityinthat
sense.
Andyouthinkit'sstartsatconception,you...Yeah,yeahunlessitcouldbeprovenotherwise.It
seemstomethathumanitystartsaconceptionthereforeabortionfromtheperspectiveofthehuman
insideofthewoman,notthewoman'sbody,thebodyinsideofthewoman.
Soholdontowherewecanbackup,'causeIthinkyou'regettingit...Somethinginteresting.
Youcanseethatatconception.We'renotdealingwithaperson,right?Yousaidthatacoupleof
minutesago,asfarasthat,Iunderstandthat,yeah,no,thereisatestortake...
03/06/20 Page6of17
davidpakmanshow­2020­03­06­commercialfree
IjustwannamakesureIdon'thaveastating.Youagreeatconception.We'renotdealingwitha
person,right?
Okay,Iknowit'sasfarasyougetit,it'sallyouropinion...Atconception.We'renotdealingwitha
person,butyousaidconceptionisthestartofhumanityonthebasisoftheDNAisinmy
understanding,yourpositioncorrectly,thedistinctionbeingpersonhoodversushumanina...
Idon'treallyunderstandthatiswhatI'mtryingtodoisbeforeImoveon,I'mtryingtoestablish
yourposition.Soifwhatyou'resayingisreally...Humanityisstartingatconception,becausethat's
whentheDNAissurfacinginrealitytheDNApre­existsthatbecausethewomanhaseggsandthe
manhasspermisn'tthatsameDNAinthemanandthewomanthatconceivethechildalreadyin
yoursense,byyourdefinition,reallyhumanityevenstarts,beforeconception.Sothenitmakesita
questionwhetheritshouldreallyhaveanythingtodowithabortion,atall.
Right?AndIthinkIwordeditslightlywrong,butthepointisthathereit'snotjusthumanDNAis
inaskinsoorwhatever,butit'sliketheuniquegeneticcode.I'mnotsureexactlyhowto
scientificallyputittoyou,butwherethere'sanew...AnewDNAthat'sseparatefromtheothers,
andthenthereare,thatwhatI...That,howdoesthatinformyourviewonabortion?
Becauseatthatpoint,Iwouldseeitashumanrightslikethatisahumanjustbecauseit'satanearly
stageofthisprocessofgrowingdoesn'tmakeitanylesshumanandhumanrightswouldenvelop
thathumanshavetherighttolife.Youcan'tjustkillahumanabortionisnotmurder,onlybecause
it'slegal,ifitwasillegalwouldbemurdermurder.Alegalterm.
Oh,Iattitude.
Ournotionnowfromthepointofconception,becauseeventhoughyouagreeatconception,it'snot
aperson,butit'shumanity,andIgettingthatit'snotthewholepositionItake.Ifthemother'slifeis
indangeratthatpointthemotherandthechildaregonnadie,sotosavethemother'slife.Ithink
abortioncouldbe...That'stheonlysenseIcouldseeitbeingpurelyagoodthing...Andnotgood.
Andsincehewasdying,buttosavetheotherslife.
Alright,verygoodteam.Nottotally.Iknowit'sallbasedonyouropinion.No,Iunderstandthat
it's...AndIhaveadifferenceofopinion,I'mnot100%followingthelogicofhowyoucametothis
butIdoappreciateyousharingwithsharingitwithme,andmaybeit'llbeusefultosomefolksthat
arelisteningtoday.